and today in world we head to Hong Kong
where pro-democracy student leaders and
the government have begun talks trying
to find some middle ground Hong Kong's
government is considering submitting a
report to China relaying the demands and
concerns of the protesters such a report
would provide Beijing with a reference
on the demonstrators opinions rather
than attempt to modify a ruling by China
on Hong Kong's leadership elections
student leader Alex Chao says these are
not concrete proposals at the government
they need to further explain it in front
of the public so that they could answer
the question from the public but whether
this solution could really settle the
current are well constitutional problem
well I'll been still need further
observation thousands of spectators
gathered to watch the much awaited
televised talks no wonder after more
than three weeks of protests that at
times turned violent people are waiting
for a solution the demonstrators have
occupied central areas of Hong Kong and
shut down a large part of the central
business district Bloomberg's Yvonne man
takes a look at how the movement is
affecting businesses in Mong Kok we are
standing here in Mong Kok it's one of
the three main protest sites that occupy
demonstrators has set up here in the
last couple of weeks and we've seen
quite a bit of scuffles between police
officers and protestors now entering
into the fourth week business owners
here say they are definitely feeling an
impact from all of this and here in
Nathan row we have a mixture of high-end
shops some of your chain stores we want
to wear them the side streets here and
that's where you get some of the
independent stores your flea markets
your electronic stores what Mong Kok is
known for and it's these employees that
tell me that they are really feeling a
hit team that Monday
I'm losing a lot of money because of
this the price for my suitcases and bags
range from only a few hundred to a
thousand I can't even tell you how much
I've lost now what is your bottom Ella
we've already had to let go of two
employees another woman and I usually
work 10 hours a day now we're working 12
and doing everything from ordering to
packing two deliveries we're sad to see
our two co-workers leave we really sorry
about it but I want to espresso upon us
that our governments are corrupt and the
system is collapsing so we stand out to
fight for a better future now students
say they do sympathize with these
business owners in the meantime the
trying their best to support some of
these local restaurants instead of going
to some other typical fast food chains
but they're hoping business owners can
also see the greater cause than what
they're fighting for which is a good of
all Hongkongers including the business
community yvonne van bloomberg hong kong
hong kong's chief executive CY Leung was
not present at the discussions between
leaders and student protesters